all right welcome back to some McHale
what castle laughs come whatever gonna
think of anything yes
so let's read this oh it's so much fun
to start off videos by reading yes let's
wait with that actually oh wow what
happen's room using um we gotta we came
from there we met an epic jump and
there's like stuff black and herb and
there's a calm music and staff
murder I guess we have to read it note
concerning recent findings it was
counterpart tension there are dangers to
health while excavating certain areas of
the temple please use extra caution when
exploring these new areas
first and foremost cave-ins seem to be
frequent oh yeah we witness on the air
here is quite husky muskie whatever and
may contain harmful spores take breaks
outside as much as needed Birmingham has
made a small batch of counteragent to
fight the symptoms finally use a
chemical a in use with what with
chemical B which is Blair er scientist
and wanna appears to be highly explosive
with interest of coagulated blood this
shouldn't be much of an issue as the
only source found so far down below
inside a large chamber dr. Lewis dep
july the sacrificial chamber let's go to
the sacrificial oh this looks perfect in
the Residential's actually let's go
there whatever
lab was somewhere I felt at what to bet
it was in my lab though
so that up I don't trust lit up I don't
trust dark either though
uh-huh whoa whoa whoa whoa
why did I say why did I [ __ ] say I
don't trust that up holy [ __ ]
don't do that again please it's just
doors no guard why are they open it's so
[ __ ] creepy okay so
anyone there I'm laughing words I need
Allah suffer this place so dark and so
though all I have is this little candle
I want to hit my balls
I'll stupid chair whoa whoa what was
that
okay we're good
Oh was bad news coming from this door
there
anyone there oh my oh my god I think oh
my god
Oh
what the heck is that oh this place is
huge
so cheese no I don't know whoa I just
I find a key
what no no no no no nonono oh crap I
hear babies
I don't like babies athletes in scary
games I have no oil what the [ __ ] I have
my Landrum I can't use it
ah this is not good I can't use my Latin
what is up with this
oh ok let's just sing the light for a
while
it's light a rake whoa what's that song
coming from
why am i walking in circles where did I
come from I can't see anything
I was useful
I swear to God I came from here right
here
here though
well what the [ __ ] no no no no no no
no
what is up with these what is up with
you what is up with the French skelet
doesn't thingy
what's up what is up do you want your
key back I don't want my key
you can have it oh man mmm I mean if I
kill the skull
well well
I've no tinderboxes what is up with this
place huh what is up with this shadow
it's creeped me out okay where came from
here
I remember now I'm going back oh the
sound is killing me oh man it's so dark
this run for it I guess
that I know where the [ __ ] I'm running
oh yeah the creeper corridor that's
where we came from
let's close the door then I guess
where's the point there so know I've
been there
now it works [ __ ] us up to that tricky
branch
really
that's not a tree branch beauty you're
so stupid okay
[ __ ] you chemical a sweet
stupid knife good
they close here
stupid liquor
I don't do that
Keeks let's go on I guess whoa whoa whoa
they're [ __ ] the words man
I've so little I left
isn't this where I came from
I need I need a chemical be hope it's
here no wait this is where I came from
ah [ __ ]
and back to the creepy music great
and creepy doors that are open now again
for some reason wait right I didn't go
here oh yeah we got the key I have a
really bad feeling about this room yeah
what's up with this
I said fire
no don't tell my have to hide in this or
something like that
uh-huh I want to see if it's possible
first doesn't seem like it all right
fine fine stupid box
no likes boxes anyway oops
and there's chemical be sweet I get the
feeling something really [ __ ] creepy
is going to happen when I walk back
though
just say jazz same oh this is closet
that's what it is
that's run fight [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm out of oil
actually a nothing creepy happen well
what do you know
let's make some scam calls
why not
what kind of laboratory is this
laboratory sucks
one third
[ __ ] great I guess I got to blow up
that
it's so dark I can't see [ __ ]
Oh can't wait to go to the tombs fun
times that was somewhere else felt that
uh stop making Madrid and we're back
with the creepy stuff spiderwebs I'm not
not mama
it sounds like something is eating my
brain or something it's also annoying
like my sanity the screwed
why can I just take that it's all stupid
rotting flesh coming from all / if a
let's go in here that
I have nothing
nothing nothing it's there
better be something here books perfect
stop cracking my head Thank You Gordon I
hope you aren't offended but I've gone
ahead for the lower levels I don't need
those chameleons yu-er
the roots of the quays will blossom lead
down and i expect to find our biggest
harvest yet it might even be Georgian
our little dream able to handle
I've been harvesting samples
your extract has to be diluted
you can hear breathing Carmelo and I
unfortunately discovered the hard way
the carrying cure scient I can have some
adverse side effects nausea anxiety
paranoia possibly even hysteria same
time
I'll rendezvous back with you tomorrow
morning by the entrance be safe don't
trigger NES
you